y
[Música]
escalada de tensión entre el reino unido
y la unión europea
el bloque reverso su decisión de
implementar controles a las
exportaciones de las vacunas de
coronavirus en la frontera entre las
irlandas tras una oleada de protestas
los líderes del bloque comunitario
reconocieron haber cometido un error
tenemos reporte desde londres
pese a que colombia mantiene cerradas
sus fronteras un caso de la variante
brasileña fue identificado en el sur del
país entretanto en la frontera con
panamá alrededor de 1000 migrantes se
encuentran bloqueados desde hace una
semana esperan que el gobierno panameño
re abra sus fronteras para continuar su
camino a eeuu
en su segundo día en el terreno los
expertos de la organización mundial de
la salud que buscan hallar los orígenes
del cob y 19 visitaron otro hospital de
luján donde se trataron algunos de los
primeros casos de la enfermedad también
fueron llevados a un museo dedicado a la
respuesta de china al brote
bienvenidos a esta emisión de noticias
en france 24 sor valentina torre sánchez
y es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos el
informativo en la unión europea' que
este sábado activó el mecanismo que
busca controlar las exportaciones de
vacunas el bloque había decidido activar
una cláusula de emergencia que habría
suspendido el protocolo de irlanda con
el fin de controlar el paso de los
fármacos en la frontera del bloque con
irlanda del norte tras una oleada de
críticas y protestas la unión europea
dio marcha atrás el primer ministro
británico boris johnson le reprochó a la
presidenta de la comisión europea úrsula
von der leyen que la decisión
comprometía los acuerdos alcanzados en
el break city nuestra corresponsal en
londres louis ha pulido amplía los
detalles
el gobierno británico confía en que
tendrá las vacunas necesarias para
continuar con su plan de inmunización de
15 millones de personas las más
vulnerables para el 15 de febrero esto
ante el temor de que no recibiría las
vacunas en el tiempo estipulado tratando
de limar las asperezas entre londres
dublín bruselas y belfast el ministro
británico del gabinete michael gov dijo
que fue un error de la unión europea
sobre las vacunas esto después de más de
24 horas frenéticas en las que la unión
europea revocó su decisión de suspender
temporalmente el acuerdo break sit
imponiendo entonces controles físicos
entre las irlandas para evitar que las
vacunas manufacturadas en su territorio
llegarán al reino unido a través de
irlanda del norte esto provocó por
supuesto furia en belfast en dublín y en
londres y también se sabe que en algunos
mandatarios de la unión europea porque
desde
acuerdo de paz de 1998 esta frontera
invisible no ha estado vigilada y ha
sido muy importante
irlanda del norte en los años de la
negociación del break sheet porque lo
que se quiere evitar es que los motivos
que causaron este conflicto en las
irlanda sean revividos por ahora londres
y bruselas han acordado que este impasse
ha sido superado pero no hay certeza de
que sea un tema recurrente más adelante
y europa continúa en alerta por la
escasez de vacunas que afronta cuando se
han registrado más de 34 millones de
contagios el continente afectado por la
tercera ola de la pandemia busca frenar
el avance de las nuevas variantes desde
las 0 horas del domingo francia
restringió la entrada de ciudadanos de
países que no pertenezcan a la unión
europea y también prohibió viajar a
países fuera del bloque alemán ya
prohibió la llegada de viajeros
procedentes de reino unido irlanda
portugal brasil y sudáfrica en portugal
la red hospitalaria está al límite
nuestra corresponsal daniela zambrano
nos amplía
la situación de los hospitales en
portugal es bastante preocupante sobre
todo la situación en las unidades de
cuidados intensivos a la fecha se han
registrado 843 personas internadas en
estas unidades y ya los hospitales no se
dan abasto de incluso esto llevado al
ministerio de salud a transferir
pacientes de unos hospitales a otros
para intentar de aliviar esta presión en
los centros de salud incluso
transferirlos desde portugal continental
hasta la isla de madeira la prensa ha
calificado el mes de enero como el más
letal en portugal pues ya suma más de
cinco mil los fallecidos sólo en lo que
va de año portugal al registrado un
total de fallecidos por kobe 19 de más
de 12.000 y más de 5000 se registraron
sólo en el mes de enero incluso la
ministra de salud de esta semana asomaba
la posibilidad de transferir pacientes
fuera de portugal para que sean ayudados
por otros países este domingo entran
nuevas medidas para intentar aliviar la
situación en portugal entre ellos sera
prohibición de salida del país a todos
los portugueses y restricciones en la
frontera continuamos ahora en américa
latina' colombia queda reportado más de
2 millones de contagios de kobe 19
informó del primer caso de la variante
brasileña en el sur del país esto pese a
que mantiene sus fronteras terrestres y
marítimas cerradas desde marzo pasado
entretanto cerca de un millar de
migrantes están varados desde hace más
de una semana en necoclí a el noroeste
del país esperan que colombia y panamá
abran las fronteras para continuar su
tránsito hacia eeuu veamos más detalles
en el informe de aurora valle
varados desde hace más de una semana
estos migrantes se esperan en la costa
colombiana la reapertura de las
fronteras con panamá
lo que queremos es por favor que de
algún lado de alguna autoridad
pertinente escuche nuestro nuestro
pedido y que nos faciliten la venta del
tiquete para poder nosotros cruzar y
continuar nos dice son de haití o de
cuba pero también hay ciudadanos
africanos de burkina faso senegal y
camerún entre otros instalados en
tiendas de campaña en necoclí quieren
intentar cruzar el peligroso golfo de
urabá para llegar a estados unidos pero
las autoridades locales denuncian un
riesgo sanitario para los habitantes y
piden un corredor humanitario en la
frontera los migrantes deciden la
apertura de la frontera
continuar su viaje pero este no es un
momento para movilizarse por el
contrario es un momento para
resguardarse con el fin de minimizar los
riesgos de contagio de hoy 19 según las
autoridades migratorias la reapertura de
los vuelos internacionales por parte de
colombia y el fin del confinamiento
desde septiembre han aumentado el flujo
de inmigrantes en la zona dicen que en
los últimos meses capturaron a 198
traficantes de personas y desmantelaron
60 redes de tráfico sin embargo 4
migrantes se ahogaron a principios de
enero al hundirse una embarcación ilegal
en la zona la misma autoridad colombiana
y el alcalde no estar diciendo
prácticamente que tenemos que alquilar
una lancha
de 400 dólares grandes tina yo no quiero
hacer eso conmigo el año pasado colombia
deportó a unos 3 mil 800 inmigrantes
ilegales la mayoría procedentes de haití
bolivia inició oficialmente su campaña
de inmunización en las ciudades de la
paz y el alto con las 20.000 dosis de la
vacuna rusa que llegó al país el pasado
jueves en el alto el primero en ser
vacunado fue un médico internista del
hospital del norte seguido de varios de
sus compañeros que tendrán que recibir
la segunda dosis del fármaco en 21 días
el presidente luís ar se anunció además
que mediante el mecanismo kóvacs el país
recibirá un millón de dosis en febrero
finalizamos en la ciudad china de wuhan
donde la misión de los expertos de la
organización mundial de la salud
continuó su investigación por segundo
día el objetivo del equipo es averiguar
tanto como sea posible sobre los
orígenes del cob y 19 y su posterior
expansión dentro y fuera de china
de visita en hoja ni los científicos de
la organización mundial de la salud
asistieron las reuniones que esperaban
desde hace mucho tiempo en los
hospitales donde fueron tratados por
primera vez casos de kobe 19 en el
instituto de biología de wuhan donde se
han estudiado numerosos casos de
coronavirus otro tipo de visitas los
expertos habrían preferido evitar como
la que hicieron a la exhibición de
propaganda que muestra lo bien que china
ha luchado contra el cob y su misión es
encontrar los orígenes del virus pero la
ms advirtió que la gente no debería
esperar respuestas todavía
el éxito no se basa en encontrar una
fuente en la primera misión
la misión es compleja no sólo porque los
orígenes del 'hobbit' datan de hace más
de un año sino también porque hay
tensión política sobre el tema china no
quiere que el informe diga que el país
pudo haber manejado mejor la crisis y
evitado que la pandemia se extendiera
por todo el mundo matando a más de 22
millones de personas
eeuu incluso bajo la administración
bailén ha pedido una investigación
sólida advirtió
sobre la interferencia china en la
misión lado ms dice que no tiene una
idea predeterminada sobre lo que ha
causado el coi 19 pero es poco probable
que su equipo investigue la teoría que
sugiere que el nuevo coronavirus se
filtró por accidente de un laboratorio
una idea que algunos miembros de la
misión han descartado como teoría de la
conspiración a ustedes gracias por
acompañarme pueden ampliar todas las
noticias en nuestra web france24
puntocom volvemos en breve con más
información
[Música]